and he has not shied away from saying  that  if you look at the definition of fascism  i would be willing to bet  my entire life savings i would be  willing to bet all the rights to my to  my book with words to my book without  words i would i would be willing to bet  all of every single dollar that i ever  will make  that karine jean-pierre  white house press secretary  has never even heard of  much less read  that the doctrine of fascism the the  essay by mussolini invents fascism for  all intents and purposes the essay by  mussolini and the italian philosopher  giovanni gentile that defines fascism  the doctrine  of fascism i guarantee you  she is she has never even heard of it  because for the libs  fascism just means something i don't  like it's lost its meaning